well you know when when I personally
engaged somebody I have a very simple
way to do that I do not look a lot into
into he certificates or something like
this what I do normally I give him our
nestling management and leadership
principles where we have established
what are the values the main ballast
that we have and I ask afterwards the
candidate to read it through carefully
and then we have a discussion about
those values and if this value scheme is
fitting with each other then we have the
sound pace for a long term relationship
and as those values are being
incorporated the creating shared value
of sustainability compliance which is
basically our pyramid where compliance
is at the base this is a minimum minimum
you have to comply with laws but you
also have to comply with your with your
own and internal business principles
then you come to the sustainability part
of it which is basically saying that
whatever we are doing the resources we
are using it has to be sustainable in
the long term and to top of it the
creating shared value which I just
mentioned water nutrition and Rural
Development if this set of values is in
line with the candidates thinking we
have a good fit if it's not in line it's
better we don't even start to work
together so I think it is very helpful
that we get a certain type of people who
are joining us and which are then
afterwards willing to stay with us now
one of the reason why the average age of
retirement at Nestle is people have
worked 25.8 years with this company
on an average out of two hundred
eighty-five thousand people in the world
when they retire the average time they
spent with our company was twenty five
point eight years so I mean an enormous
amount and this is because the values
are working well together